as we mentioned earlier senate
negotiation
senate negotiators are running out of
time to craft new gun laws before
congress leaves for its fourth of july
recess
there have been 278 mass shootings in
the u.s this year let me repeat that 278
mass shootings in the u.s this year
according to gun violence archive a
non-profit research group one of the
responses that congress is considering
would expand access for treatment of
mental illness chief medical
correspondent dr john lepuk looked at
the connection between mental illness
and gun violence he found that it's very
complicated
possible active shooter at the top after
every mass shooting
shots being fired we hear a common
refrain people with mental illness are
getting guns our inability to deal with
mental illness mental illness and hatred
pulls the trigger people with mental
illness are no more likely to commit
acts of violence than people in the
general population we spoke with the
heads of both the american and canadian
psychiatric associations dr rebecca
brendell and dr doug earnest compared to
other places in the world does the
united states have a significantly
increased rate of mental illness the
rates of mental illness in the united
states are really quite similar to the
rates of mental illness in canada and in
other countries around the world despite
those similar rates of mental illness
rates of firearm violence in the united
states and canada are very different in
2020 there were 277 firearm related
homicides in canada and more than 19 000
in the united states
accounting for differences in population
the rate in the u.s was more than eight
times higher so that's a really big
difference
that it cannot be attributable just to
differences in the rate of mental
illness what is causing somebody then to
commit such a horrendous act as a mass
shooting if it's not mental illness
saying that there's no mental illness
does not mean that there's no
psychological distress or there are no
factors in an individual's life that
might lead somebody to commit an act of
violence there are a variety of factors
relating to the risk of violence doctors
brendell and ernest say blaming mental
illness for mass shootings diverts
attention from the actual risk factors
social connectedness substance use
disorders
including acute intoxication anger
or resentment for having been mistreated
or not fitting in people with a history
of antisocial or violent behavior of
course people who may find themselves in
a situation that they perceive threat we
do know
that the best predictor of future act of
violence is a past act of violence
but there's no one profile of an
individual who commits an act of
violence
both dr brendell and dr ernest say when
people are in psychological distress a
key factor is having access to the means
to commit violence during times of
vulnerability when people are on the
edge of maybe or maybe not doing an act
access to lethal means
is really
a fateful factor in canada the estimated
number of firearms for every 100
residents is 35. in the united states
it's 120.
we have more firearms than people in the
united states and so that difference
really highlights the number one risk
factor for gun violence which is the
presence of a firearm so
how do you figure out how to prevent
these terrible deeds we need to do
systematic research about different
kinds of firearm violence including mass
shootings to help us understand what
commonalities exist and what risk
factors might be present and doing
something about those risk factors means
appreciating the complexity of the
problem there's no one size fits all
when we're talking about these
relatively rare although all too common
incidences of mass violence
dr john leprough joins us right now we
heard in the piece that just because
there's no mental illness that doesn't
mean there's no psychological distress
what's the difference and why is it
important to point that out
it may seem like you're splitting hair
saying there's a difference but the
mental health experts we spoke to feel
so strongly that there's already such
stigma attached to mental illness they
don't want to increase it they're saying
look the research shows that the
presence of mental illness is not a good
way of predicting whether somebody is
going to commit violence so what is a
good way and that's where you get the
severe psychological distress and you
know you've heard in the piece lots of
different reasons for it we all have
seen in the profiles people who just
reach a snapping point a breaking point
they snap it's very hard to figure out
who those people are going to be there
are so many different causes because it
happens in a moment's time it can happen
like that it can be building up over
time but it's hard to predict who that
is there's a lot of discussions about
what to do about that but for this piece
today the focus the bottom line that i
would like people to walk away with is
that the mental health experts really
want people when there is one of these
shootings to not
reflexively just blame mental illnesses
i'm sorry it's so much more complicated
than that so glad you did this piece
because it shows once again it's not the
mental illness necessarily it's the
access to the guns well and you can have
severe psychological distress with or
without underlying mental illness it's
very complicated we need more research
access to the guns and ideology as well
yeah more guns more gun deaths it's
pretty much very well done
and the numbers 100 to 20 more guns than
people
thank you john poop thank you